now turning to an issue that is gaining
a lot of attention because of the war in
ukraine yes conflict is spotlighting the
struggles that many refugees face
putting down roots in a new country more
than 3.1 million refugees from around
the world now live in the united states
in both 2020 and 2021 about 12 000 new
refugees were admitted many of them are
children adriana diaz spoke with a group
of young refugees living in chicago who
are part of a community called reach
they talked about assimilating to the
united states and their memories of the
countries they used to call home
what i do remember is
sound of gunshots sound of
pain some of people stuck in the war for
40 years
that's all i remember from afghanistan
in burma there's military coup
so we can't go back to burma muhammad do
you remember what it was like in syria
or why you guys left we left because
there was a lot of war and it wasn't
pleasant lots of shooting to hear
children speak so plainly about war and
human suffering is not easy we came to
the u.s because my mom wanted like
a better education and just
life in general
my name is noer and my my intention for
today was to learn more about animals
but despite the odds these kids have
found hope and bonds with each other
through the similar stories of their
parents sacrifice how hard was it for
you guys to get used to life here in
chicago and making american friends and
and learning the culture when you step
out there's nobody really you can talk
to there's nobody you can share
your feelings to you feel very very
alone it was hard because we didn't
really know any english
so we couldn't communicate unfamiliar
language culture and unspoken societal
rules keep many refugees in their homes
but so much time indoors can deepen
feelings of isolation especially for
kids i was a little bit depressed
because i literally couldn't do anything
except stay at home but as i talked more
in school i started making more friends
and i started explaining my feelings
because what happens when you keep your
feelings bottled up you won't make
friends if you don't open your emotions
or talk to anyone
getting kids to open up and socialize is
the goal of reach a non-profit in
chicago that connects refugee youth
through activities i was approached by
several members of the local refugee
community they were worried because a
lot of their sons and daughters were
facing a lot of academic failure
social isolation
bullying i want us to think about a
couple of things that you want to try to
find shawna wills has worked with the
refugee community here in chicago for
more than 30 years and she knows the
pitfalls they're expected to
learn a new language adapt to new
culture understand a new school system
and then do that while also finding the
right peers they feel like they need to
fit in and so they're easy targets for
gang members we've seen a lot of refugee
young people who've lost their lives to
violence here so they're even more
vulnerable to gang violence and
recruitment very much so when they come
to this country for a better life yeah
you're going to make me cry because it
really we've lost a lot of kids
that's what keeps her on this now
lifelong mission to help these kids grow
into their own identities while becoming
familiar with their new country
the program exposes them to new
experiences designed to build confidence
and it also uses nature as therapy the
most important thing that happens is
that they start to feel a sense of
belonging
are you ready for this yeah already one
look at their faces and you see the
impact are you ready
what have you gained through reach a lot
of confidence being more social more
activities like more talking to people
reach makes me feel comfortable and
confident i was like shy and i wasn't
willing to go
out there and you know express myself so
does the us feel like home now yes
definitely
us feels like home because now everyone
is
equal people aren't
saying nice things they're not judging
anyone anymore i have a sense of
community
i don't feel like the odd one out
anymore i don't feel left out when we
first came here i had no confidence
in talking to anyone but now i feel more
confident in school and talking to
people
not being shy i kind of feel that the
united states is made of millions of
different stars and you know
by stars i mean different nations
different cultures and i think
one of the stars is my culture it is me
it is where i belong
for cbs mornings adriana diaz chicago
he said that very well the united states
is made up of a lot of different stars
you know when you're a kid you just want
to fit in that's right you just want
friends and you just want to fit in it's
good that they're now starting to feel
that you can only imagine what it's like
when you just move across the country
neighborhood and you go to a new school
that's hard
from another country and trying to fit
in you don't speak the language the
culture is different and sometimes
people aren't as welcoming as they
should be kids you know yeah um until
they learn how to be adults too right
and i think we all collectively can take
a little bit of what reach is doing in
chicago and apply it across the board i
mean you never know how isolated
somebody
is an adult a family of course kids um
but i think we all can look in the
mirror and say maybe we can do a little
bit more right for somebody who might
feel a little isolated i always say
kindness always works that's right all
levels it doesn't matter what you're
doing kindness always works that's right
gail i love that piece adriano yes well
done